the last couple days as michael
mentioned i want to talk about these
apprentices
bill belichick's struggling apprentices
if you really think about it uh
nora okay so matt patricia uh having a
hard time in detroit
uh bill o'brien started off uh 01-4 so
he's got his problems uh
joe judge uh bad team right now
with the giants and then brian flores is
one and three
i'm just looking at the current guys
right there those four guys
at cliff kingsbury i don't know
just focusing on patricia flores
judge and o'brien is there any common
denominator besides
working for bill belichick or is it just
a coincidence
that all of these guys are struggling in
your opinion well there's a
there's a common denominator with
o'brien
patricia and i think it's a little
unfair to say with judge because it's
incredibly early but
the common denominator there is that
they've had a lot of conflicts with
their players
and i wonder if you know one of the
things that i think
uh is hypothesized about why those
belichick apprentices
end up struggling is that they don't
know how to be themselves or they're
they feel like they need to be sort of a
carbon copy of
bill and carry with them some of the
rigid adherence to discipline and
[Music]
for lack of a better word uh
i'm trying can i curse on this show yeah
go ahead gus cuss it out
hardassery like that's the best way to
put it i think that's right
all right it is for me i try and keep it
clean uh
but patricia i mean
glover quinn's on instagram saying you
didn't inherit a bad team what are you
talking about that you think you've
worked to do in detroit
you could darius slay like you could go
down a list of guys that
either have still been there or have
left
and have either openly feuded with the
coach or just had not nice things to say
and it seems like that happened i mean
it certainly happened with
deandre hopkins in houston where
they just get in these these fights with
players
and it seems to come from
sort of being stubborn and
my way or the highway so i i think that
might be a part of it
and whether that's just sort of part of
those guys personalities or maybe it's
something about coming from new england
where there is such a culture
and feeling very strongly about wanting
to instill your own
but not necessarily having the track
record where players will fall in line
as easily
that ecosystem i think can be very tough
to navigate for some of those guys but i
also think that they
you know i think patricia is certainly
culpable in
egging on those those fights and it's
it's funny when we were doing um the
ringer nfl show on
on sunday we were kind of joking about
how
you know the best thing it's like a
miracle that he hasn't gotten in a feud
with matt stafford is the way it seems
like things going so
i don't think that that's across the
board i doubt flores will
will do that it doesn't seem like he i
mean i guess they've shipped out some
guys that they didn't see as like
culture guys but
those three i think that's a common
denominator i don't know that that goes
for all of them though
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports